has there been a pinch me moment for you
in the last year was there a moment like
I can't believe this is happening right
now so that there's so many I know is
there one that you're just like I am
stressed out I can't leave this is
happening right now this little may
never recover a couple of them that
happened this year I mean when my the
Time magazine cover happened the hundred
most influential I was like are you sure
I asked my publicist three times I was
like are you sure it's me then when I
got the Padma Shri in India and both of
those happen 10 days apart like a week
apart I was like what is going on there
were a few moments like the Oscars you
know being the second most googled and
after Leonardo DiCaprio he won an Oscar
yeah finally right I was I was just an
address well you're gonna win one day
you're gonna win it I know you weren't
um I'm so many just yeah what wonderful
moments that have happened to me the
show going to about two hundred sixteen
territories within our first season
dubbed in 56 languages I see myself
speaking French and and Japanese and
like Java and Italy you know what moment
that I really thought was spectacular is
when I saw you at the Correspondents
Dinner and you're standing out next to
President Obama and Michelle Obama like
this is incredible what did she say to
you what did he say to you what was that
moment all about you know that was so
amazing they were about 500 other actors
yeah waiting to meet them and they were
so graciously just standing there but
when I went up to prayer President Obama
and Anna Michelle Obama they both knew
of me they both knew of my work
President Obama spoke to me about the
Prime Minister Modi coming to America
and how he had spent time in India and
Michelle Obama spoke to me about the
work that I've done with UNICEF and how
she works very she works a lot for the
girl child and how she wanted me to
collaborate with her to me what was so
amazing was their incredible knowledge
of me I mean Who am I and the biggest
game of things you know so it's really
great to have leaders who actually take
such attention to detail and I was very
impressed with that now you live in New
York they're not gonna be president
anymore enough - what are you feeling
good I I live in Mumbai what exciting
one Donald truck fee like about the
whole situation you okay well look I'm
not American so but I am working in a
media but I do see that there are a lot
of you know mixed mixed feelings about
about this presidential election and the
way I see it is it is what it is and we
all need to just come together and make
sure that you know you you create the
country that you want to see and you
create the country that you want to live
in yes good answer I like that thank you
they watch this this is incredible
that's coming your debut film your sexy
villain your coming out you were
performing with Zac Efron and the one
and only Dwayne Johnson how was being on
set with them
I adore both of them yeah I mean I mean
the entire cast I came in and out of the
film because I was filming Quantico
while I was filming they watched so it
was pretty haphazard they had to shoot
me out but the cast of a-team was so
wonderful the film is going to be
hilarious I'm very excited that you know
my my debut American movies not
conventional that is true yeah but I
play like an villain and and that's kind
of fun it was a Lomo Baywatch run you
got that down as well I was teaching now
you agree that he's people sexiest men
alive during Johnson I do get him and I
are kind of buddies to you Yeah right
Dwayne you and I we kind of hang out
together yeah listen what great he's an
awesome guy more than anything just
really nice and such a gentleman and I I
I remember after he he one I tweeted him
saying exactly that that sexy is what
sexy does oh nice um and you know it
doesn't matter what you look like or I
mean though it helps if you look like
what more than anything it is who you
are and what you behave like and how you
come across to people and doing is one
of the most humble really really nice
people that I've known can you tell them
we should work out I've been pushing
that maybe you me
him can like put it on universe go for a
workout workout yeah you and him can do
that cuz it's an acquired taste that I
was acquired yeah he's so great all
three of us you shall watch you'll just
watch I'm coming DJ you heard that way
we're gonna make this happen he was just
in the news yesterday she was also
making a fast and furious right after he
make this made the film with you and he
made some comments about his colleagues
what are your thoughts on that I didn't
know what comments he made some slamming
comments he made some comments about
some of the people he was working with
is that okay I mean is it okay to kind
of reflect what the people you were
working with and making those comments I
mean people are people yeah I have the
pretentiousness right I don't think that
just because you're a celebrity and a
public person you always have to be
diplomatically correct feelings are
feelings emotions are emotions and
experiences are experiences and if I
have a bad experience with someone and
I'm okay saying that it's fine I don't
believe that just because you're a
public person you should be pretentious